- Morning vlog.
(hip hop beat)
Last night I was recruiting
a guy for VaynerSports
so I had to set an alarm
'cause I was in an event
in Chattanooga and then I didn't realize
it was still on PM so I set my alarm.
So this morning I woke up just randomly.
I actually think it was a
skip in my sound machine
from a call potentially that I like,
woke up and I looked at my phone,
I knew I was in trouble
'cause the alarm didn't go off
- Yeah.
and I grabbed my phone
and it was 5:09 and I
have a 6:00 AM flight.
And I made it, Chattanooga Airport.
Perfect.
- Did you have to
like cruise through or was it pretty...
- You know what's crazy?
I was in the car by like 5:15.
- Yep.
And it's 15 minutes, 5:30
and I was like, okay I can
get through it in four minutes
and I'll be good 'cause
as long as you're there
10 minutes before...
- [Man] Uh-huh.
- I got there and the line was massive
and like literally four people were like
this is the longest I've ever seen it
in the history of the Chattanooga Airport.
And I was like.
So I cut people.
It was very nice of people.
I was like, please, and
still it took forever
but then I got there and it was like 5:50
and they still hadn't boarded the plane.
It was good.
- Good stuff.
We made it!
Alex?
How do we... We may need to
create a separate situation
where it's hotter.
I don't know what to do, maybe in here,
you know, something to think about.
Can you investigate?
(inaudible)
Yeah.
- You sat that up?
- Yeah, I'm also potentionally
getting sick, so...
(fake sneezes)
I'm kidding, of course.
It's all mental.
By the way, I was 100%...
I should be super sick right now.
My mental break through, I haven't slept.
I've slept like six hours in two days.
I'm a mess right now.
I woke up and like should have been dead.
I can't even believe how I feel right now.
The brain is so underrated Marcus.
- There's also something around,
like a lot of corporations
are moving to like this
entrepreneur type of like mentality.
Like, trying to get there
teams to think more small
and start products on their own,
so I think there would be
value in like meeting...
- [Man] Almost like org
structured meetings.
- Yes, exactly.
- I want to make a video
rant today about this
entrepreneur subject and I
want it to start with Kim
just saying that naturally
and I'm going to Segway into
my rant I've been wanting
to talk about this
and that will be cool and it's just time.
Because I'll just make my
rant right now which is
there is no fucking
entrepreneurs in these companies.
They don't create the framework
- Right
for an entrepreneur.
It's like being a CFO at VaynerMedia.
(laughter)
There's no framework for it.
Like...
- Yeah.
It sucks.
They're like be an entrepreneur
but then all your bonuses
are provocative on the internal MMM,
and hitting the $4 CPM on programmatic.
Anyway, cool.
(rap music)
- Episode 262, Ryan Holiday,
you guys were talking about
marketing, talking about all
that stuff in my new apartment,
painting my new apartment
and you said something about
documenting versus creating.
- Creating.
That was like bam!
I was like, this guys onto something.
So on confidence, just as an
encouragement to when you talk,
like how people react, and
what they listen and what they
do about it, I was like,
I'm going to work there
for whatever time is going to
be, I'm going to work there.
And that was August 10th.
August 22nd, I was on
the phone with Cecilla.
It was one of those things, I was like...
- Good for you, brother.
(inaudible)
- If this guys talking about
lets do something about it,
let's really do something about it.
So you know, encouragement
to you that people
- Thank you.
are listening.
The other thing I wanted
to talk about is parenting.
- Yes.
- I think I am onto
something when it comes to
dads and fitness.
- Interesting.
- I have an idea that I
want to start pretty soon.
From you perspective, I
know the tools that I need,
I know the information
that I want to put it out,
how do you choose the
best platform to start,
because obviously...
- Can you do a podcast?
- That's funny you say that.
Yes, I can.
- The answer is 100% that.
- That's funny.
I'm going to write it down in big letters.
Yeah, it's funny that
you said that because...
- There's noting else to say, brother.
- Yeah, I'm going...
- Can I tell you why?
- Yeah, yeah, sure.
- It's passive consumption.
- Yeah.
- And it's still...
Do you know how I think of all
this stuff, like Real Estate.
- Sure.
- Podcast is on the third
street off the beach right now.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Social media is on the other
side, like 29 streets in.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
- Yep, yep, yep.
- And AR or Crypto are
on the beach right now.
Do you understand?
- Yeah.
- I like the third
because the problem with
being on the beach is you're
pumped when it's Malibu
but you lose a fuck load
of money when it's Smalibu.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- Do you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Podcasting.
- Yeah.
It was great meeting you, man.
- Such a pleasure.
Vlog, I'm going to do
something fun right now.
You can get in here, Justin.
To vlog...
Leave a comment and say I want the book
and you will get one of the proof copies.
I'm going to put it here until
we send it and that's that.
Get out.
(rap music)
Quick take, I'm going to
leave my quick opinions
on things on the vlog right now.
Just coming through "The
Wire", Facebook adds a
snooze button which lets you,
I guess, snooze people out.
Facebook adds a snooze but
for muting people, groups,
and pages for 30 days.
Today's launch is a new feature designed
to give users more control.
I've been saying it forever,
everyone's like Facebook
makes me do this, Facebook
screws me, dah, dah,
Facebook's only value is your
attention and they will always
make the best product for
you and they will continue
to do things for you,
for you to stay inside of
Facebook and Instagram.
Your attention is Facebook's
product that they sell.
They're very smart, and
don't take it for granted
and actually give a shit
about you from a macro
because it's in it for
them and that's why that
product will continue to be awesome.
Facebook and Amazon do things for you
that are then for them.
That's kind of the way I
think about it, nonetheless,
a very interesting feature
that once again proves
it's for Facebook to do
the things that you want
and that's how they'll win
and that is the always,
that is always the best strategy,
which is be consumer centric
and you will have the leverage.
Good job, Facebook.
Another little micro headline,
little feature that may not
be understood in the macro,
which is do it for the consumer
and the consumer's
admiration, spend attention,
will give you the leverage for what
you're trying to accomplish.
You want some real advice, like real?
- [Man] Yeah.
- If you guys understood that
you could accomplish nothing
for the next eight years and I mean zero,
and still be young as fuck
and like dominate life,
you would get on a plane
and spend the next two years
going everywhere because
there's no downside
and there's nothing but upside.
- [Man] Yep.
So do it.
- Yeah, I mean, everybody's
playing there 20's backwards.
Everybody's got such a chip
on their shoulder between
debt or to prove to somebody
that they've got something,
that they go right into
dumb shit to start getting
short money and like do the
right thing or prove something,
they need to punt...
Everybody should fucking...
The 22 to 30 year old play,
should be even more
ridiculous than the 18 to 22.
And one day, I think it will be.
I think 22 to 30 is going
to get real fucking fun.
I'm pissed that I'm going to miss it.
I think you people should fucking punt it.
I think you guys should
fucking go around the world
as a horde, live in shitty
places, like learn, taste,
- Yeah, absolutely.
play 100%.
- I just wanted to show
you something really cool.
Do you like magic?
- Yeah, I mean, I've been
getting magicked on like by all
these Instagram and YouTube...
You know what's funny?
I really like magic.
I now really understand what
the fuck people are doing.
It's actually what I do, which is...
What I like about magic is
it's manipulation of attention.
Like, I did not know how you...
What you're about to do,
I did not know how you did it a year ago.
I know exactly what you're about to do.
And now what's happening,
when people do magic on me,
I'm looking at nothing that
they want me to look at
and I'm trying to guess
what they're actually doing
and the last time dude did magic on me,
that's like this big Instagrammer,
it was shit for me because I could see
everything he was doing,
though a year ago I would
have been like what the fuck.
(laughter)
- [Man] Who was the one doing magic?
- I don't know.
- [Justin] The crazy as fuck...
The first guy, you're talking about?
- Not Juliene.
I mean, David Blaine's a
good friend of mine, right?
- [Man] Uh-huh.
- And so, like, that shit was like...
When I didn't know what
the magicians were doing
and he's so good, it was
like, fuck me, right?
- [Man] Right.
- But now I actually...
I'm actually going to get
drinks with him soon because
now I'm excited to see how
good he is with his craft.
It's so crazy, you're
probably the first guys that's
tried to do this to me since
I've completely cemented.
The last time dude did magic on me...
(mumble)
Oh, at the soccer thing.
- [Justin] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
It was the craziest thing, now.
This guy is really considered
good because I looked into it
and I could see what he was
doing and it's interesting
because it's what I
think I do as a person.
I live my life the way magicians
run their world, which is,
it seems like I'm doing something to you
but I'm doing something
else and I'm trying to teach
everybody that's what I'm doing,
so you guys can do it too.
Wish you could see the...
I'm getting goosebumps right now.
The last time, the time
before that, it clicked.
So when he came, dude in London
or where was I, Amsterdam?
Sweden.
- Sweden, yeah.
- I was like ready and the
reason I'm telling you is
now I'm so ready.
It was crazy.
I could have really blew up
dude's spot and I held off
because I'm like, I wanted
to respect the game.
Now it's going to be a funny game,
when magicians try to do shit to me,
of how fast and good are they
at that thing because I'm not
looking at the thing that they
want me to look at anymore.
- [Magician] You ready?
- I'm ready.
- Okay let's do it.
- With all that said.
- [Justin] All right, no pressure.
- It's fine.
We're just going to have fun.
- He's one of the top
guys at the magic castle.
- I believe you.
I just really wanted to tell him that
because it blew my mind.
It's interesting, right?
It's an interesting way
to articulate it, right?
- [Magician] It's true.
- It was really interesting
and now I'm, like, into it.
All right, go ahead.
- So am I.
I love it.
(laughter)
All right, deck of cards.
- Yes.
- YOu're going to stop
me at any card you like
- I understand.
and whatever card you say
stop at, is the card you take.
Okay, go for it.
- Stop.
- Yeah, good.
We're going to put that card,
let's put it right there.
You're not going to look at it,
I'm not going to look at it.
We're going to put this
bottle right on top of it.
All right, my job is to find every card
that's related to that card.
- Okay.
For example, if you had like
a three of diamonds, three
of hearts, clubs, and spades
is my job to get out without
you knowing the card.
- Okay.
- This is what we're going to do.
Let's do...
(mumbles)
I don't think any of those are your card.
Actually, the first one that
comes to the top, like that.
You see that?
And I know you saw that,
it kind of popped up.
- Mm-hmm.
- The ace of hearts which is interesting.
We'll put that down right there.
Can you hold your hands out
because the magics going to
happen in your hands right here.
And to go like that.
Right there.
Now let's take a look.
The next card goes on top.
Now, take a look at it.
Is that another ace?
- It sure is.
- Okay, so it's not that one.
It's...
What was the first one,
was it a heart or the...
- A heart.
- It was the heart.
Okay, we'll put that one down there.
Hold you hands out.
Okay, we'll go, one, two, three.
Let's see.
So, now I have to kind of
look and assess the situation,
see what I've got here.
We'll just give it a
few shuffles, like that.
Remember how you said
stop at the beginning?
- Yeah.
- You're going to say stop
again whenever you like.
- Stop.
- Right there.
Take a look.
That card right there, the ace of clubs.
- I love it.
- You're the magician, not me.
- What's interesting is, first of all,
90% of what's happened so
far, I have no fucking idea.
That one I understood.
- Huh.
- I never would have before.
Because I was looking at
something, it's super cool.
It's super cool.
It actually...
You'll find this interesting.
I actually now want to have this talent,
where before I didn't even think about it
because it's a real skill.
There's two different things going on.
The skill of like being
able to maneuver shit
and then the skill of story
telling and all the other stuff.
Yeah.
- And still keep...
- Like, I know exactly
what that is, you know?
And like to me...
- What's that card?
- That's the ace of spades.
- Okay, that's the card isn't it.
- You know, like...
Oh, oh.
- Oh, shit.
- Shit.
- I'm sorry, those are the...
(screaming)
- That's what's up, man.
That's what's up.
That is what's up.
To me, that will forever...
Honestly, that is so fucking gangster.
I have so much respect for
that and I'm so grateful that
that is what I'm actually
doing in life, with my life.
- That's amazing.
That's a gift for you.
Thank you.
- Dude, that was so badass.
- Thank you, thank you.
- That was so good, so good.
And I made it so much better
by talking and stuff, right?
I made it so much better.
I gotta go.
See ya.
- No problem.
- All right, guys, take care of yourself.
- Take it easy, Gary, thank you.
- Hello, New York, and welcome
to the very first episode
of New York City Pulse.
A brand new show that
dives deep into the mindset
of New Yorkers with the relentless drive,
in pursuit of their ambition
and our very first guest today
absolutely exemplifies this description.
The man sitting next to me here is
the one and only, Gary Vanyerchuk.
I know you have siblings.
- Yes.
You have two younger siblings
is that right?
- Yes.
- So, with your father's
absence for most of the time
did that force you to step up at home into
- 100%.
more of a leadership role.
I think it's a good observation
that people don't...
I'm already optimistic for your show
because I think it's a good observation
that I don't remember a
lot of people asking me.
That's exactly right.
I mean, me and my mom
are only 20 years apart.
- Mmm.
- So when I was 14, she was 34.
Like, Justin, how old are you?
- [Justin] 21.
- Justin's 21, I'm 42.
My mom...
I'm older than my mom,
like, our gap is bigger
than me and my mom.
And I feel like we are contemporaries.
He doesn't feel like we're contemporaries,
but he doesn't think I'm
as old as I actually am
compared to him, given like my vibe,
but that's how my mom was, right?
Like, duh, she was my
mom, but we were like...
Yeah, she was 34, I was
14 and we were like...
My dad wasn't around so like,
you know, I babysat the kids,
and I like, set the tone
and I was a leader in my
house from the get, for sure.
- And that definitely paved the road
for you to be an effective
leader, leading VaynerMedia?
- 100%.
100,000%.
I think that's a very astute observation
that a lot of people have not made.
I listen by watching what people do.
Like I already know what
sneakers he's wearing, right?
I'm paying attention to how
you're wearing your hair.
- [Host] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Host] What do you think?
- I think it's different.
- [Host] Okay.
- I think it's kind of like
Fez from "That 70's Show".
I think it's a throwback.
- Okay.
- And honestly, I took note of that.
I'm like what does that mean?
I like that shit.
So, I've learned how to
listen without talking.
Excuse me, I've learned how to listen
without the other person
talking, my whole life.
That's how you do sales.
You know, I used to do
baseball card shows.
I would stand by a table.
He would walk table to table to table,
and he would look at my cards.
He would not say anything
because he's a shopper.
I'd say, can I help you and he'd say, no.
Well, I could have checked out
and been lazy, but I wasn't.
I would then spend my time looking at him,
without being creepy.
I'd like kind of like look and be like,
let me know if I can
help you with anything.
I would watch.
I would watch what he would look at.
What made him buy, why, who?
Then I'd watch him at the table
if he went to the left and
right, see what he did there.
I learned how to...
Then I did retail.
I stood behind a register all day
and just would watch people.
So, I watch.
- Right, but that's in person sales,
but now you're leading a much
bigger company and you don't
have that ability to watch
other people as much now, so...
- Yeah, but guess what?
Once you have that seed, you
understand how to scale it.
- Got it.
- Here's the part, that I
have that I figured out,
as of magic.
Magic.
No expectations of others.
I do great by him, I do great
by him, I do great by him.
I eat his shit.
I do great, I do great, I do great.
Then he goes does something,
something good happens,
he can help me, and he doesn't?
For some weird reason,
I don't give a fuck.
And so many people get crippled.
So many people do very
little and expect...
Do you know most people
give with expectation.
- Yes.
- What the fuck am I getting out of this?
- Nothing.
Thank you for doing this.
- I mean, this is your first fucking show.
Nine people are going to watch.
- That's right.
Maybe less.
- But now,
you're going to have...
Do you know what your guests
are going to look at now?
You're going to go and
fucking say, Gary Vaynerchuk
was my first fucking guest.
You're going to get 10
times the quality guests
you would have gotten.
You're going to get...
Guest number four of this show
is the quality of the guest
you would have been guest 147,
just by me allocating this 15 minutes.
- And that's again, an example of giving
without expecting in return.
- That's right, and if you
go on to become Larry King,
and I need to promote
some shit in 21 years.
- Well you know who has you.
- Or not and this is the key.
That would be great and I hope so
and surely I think about
that, but if you said no,
through your booker, I
would say to my ad man,
I would say that's some shit.
Ad man would be like fucking,
motherfucker, you know?
But I would never be...
The extent of it would
be like that fucking kid,
that fucking kid would
be nowhere if I didn't do
the first fucking episode,
which I wouldn't believe,
by the way, because if
somebody gets somewhere,
you might have been part of
their path but I don't...
You know?
- Right, right, right.
- Maybe I accelerated it, but
we all accelerate each other.
Maybe I wouldn't be where I was if
Justin didn't make a video.
Like, there's a million what ifs.
Here's what I would say for some reason,
after about a minute of
being like, fuck that kid,
I hope his show gets canceled, you know,
like competitive shit,
I'd be like, maybe he's in a bad place,
maybe he's going through a
divorce, maybe he forgot,
maybe he thinks about it
differently than I did.
I have empathy, man.
Empathy is a powerful drug.
- So at 19, you probably
had some vision of
what your life would
look like at 42, right?
- Yeah.
- So how does what has actually happened
compare to that vision that
you had when you were 19?
Are you there, did you meet it?
- I don't live in the suburbs.
I thought that.
I can't see anything else.
I knew I'd be successful,
like really successful.
- What told you that?
- The fact that I was
already successful at 19,
selling toys and baseball
cards and like, I was, dude,
I wish I was documenting my whole life.
You know, like people
don't know my true story.
Meaning, people hear this story,
I went into my dad's
business and did $3 million.
Immediately, when you hear
that statement, you're like,
Dad put him on.
People don't know that I built
my dad's business for him
and left Wine Library at 34 with nothing
in equity in that company, right?
People don't know that
like, I never paid myself
that much money, so I
had not that much money.
People don't know what it
looks like to have no money
and make $3,000 a weekend,
pre-internet, as a 15 year old, in 1990.
That's what I did with no
fucking money, motherfuckers.
I went traded with kids, made good trades,
went to a baseball card show, sold some,
saved my $80, bought more stuff.
It takes talent to make $3,000.
99% of you audience doesn't
know how to make $3,000 a week.
I did it at 15 with no fucking money.
So, I knew I was fucking, all time.
- From the get?
- From the fucking get.
You know what I was doing at 19?
I was calling my mom at college, crying,
saying I don't want to go
into the family business
even though I want to
help because one day,
everybody will hold that over me
and say that I was given something.
That's why I don't own
anything in Wine Library.
Ultimately, I never
wanted anything because
I don't want anybody to
have any excuse not to chase
their dream and work fucking hard
because I knew I'd be the
greatest example of it of all time
and I didn't want them
to have something on me.
I want people to understand,
if you're good enough,
you will win.
You have to be patient and
you have to put in the work.
If this show is going to
be big, it will be big.
You just got to put in the
work and deploy the patience.
Let's go rapid fire round.
- Rapid fire round.
- I'll go fast.
- Let's talk legacy.
- Yes.
- Okay, death is a...
- Scares the shit out of me.
- Scares the shit out of you.
- Yes, I hate it, don't want to die.
- You don't want to talk about it?
- I'll talk about it.
I definitely don't want to die.
- So, look, you seem
like the type of person
who wants to be in control of everything.
- Yes.
- So now, if you had the luxury of
being able to control when you go...
- Yes.
- In a perfect world, when would that be?
- Nine...
After you accomplish
something, when you're ripe old age?
- I can go tomorrow from a...
No, no, no, no, no.
It's not about putting
points on the board.
That's already done.
When I made $100,000 a year,
that was my only weird thing on the board.
Yes, I want to buy the Jets.
- Cha-ching, I won.
- Yes, I want to buy the Jets,
but I want to try to buy the
Jets more than getting to.
You know, the thrill of the
chase more than the, right?
I just want to live forever.
It's fun.
What the fuck do I want to die for?
- You want to be immortal?
- Yeah, hell yeah, but if you
had to but a number on it,
I don't know, $9 billion, fine.
Maybe I'll get mad when I get up there
and instead wish I did
$80 billion, but like,
$9 billion's fine.
- Final question, Gary,
fill in this blank,
Gary Vanyerchuk is...
- The greatest.
- The greatest, and
with that we wrap up...
- I have to preface it
because Muhammad Ali actually
took it, and he deserves it,
and it should stay there.
Gary Vanyerchuk was the
disproportionate best entrepreneur
of a generation in, in helping
the other entrepreneurs,
while he was getting his.
Got it?
Gary Vanyerchuk
- I can agree to that.
was the best entrepreneur in
helping other entrepreneurs
while getting his.
So it doesn't mean that I'm
going to make the most money.
It doesn't mean that I'm
going to be Elon Musk or,
you know, bazucs or
bazos, the most, right,
or the most iconic and
change the game, Elon,
and things like that.
It doesn't mean that I
was just like an author
that helped a lot of people or
Oprah or Tony Robbins, right?
I was the best at
building the biggest thing
and trying to drag everybody with me,
because I didn't think
any of their success
came at my expense.
This, nobody that will look like me ever,
would ever do this interview, ever.
- Right.
- Ever.
- It's the legacy that you're after.
- Ever, ever, ever, ever.
You understand?
- Yes.
- Nobody who's going to end up
as big of a winner, as I am,
would have ever done this
interview and that is my legacy.
So, what's cooking?
- Same old, you know?
Some good stuff.
I think I was here maybe nine months ago.
- Yep.
- And I got tired, and Josh
is really starting to...
He's been following me forever,
but we're doing to play list.
And I've got to tell you this,
- It matters.
this shit is working.
- No shit.
- And...
- And when you're smart
enough to hire somebody who is
following my stuff, it
speeds up the learning curve.
- Oh, yes.
- A lot of people
are going to go out, right,
who are watching right now
and go hire just a video kid
and they're going to say go watch Gary V.
- I gave him every book...
- How long did you
consume my stuff before?
- [Justin] I think like nine months.
- Right, it was big.
Like, Justin was like further...
Because there's nuances in my shit
and it's way more nuance
than you could dig.
You can ask him, it's even
crazier, its crazier good in...
- We're not at the level of your...
- No, it's not that.
It's not about, like,
success or skills or scale,
it's about doing the right thing.
My whole thing is so fundamentally strong
because it's not selfish.
- Yeah.
Good to see you,
- Good to see you.
as always.
- Great to meet you.
- [Man With Hat] Thank you, sir.
- So nice to meet you.
- [Woman] You too.
- Take care.
- [Gary On Recording]
Because that's the only way
they're going to get it.
- Right.
- [Gary On Recording] Period.
(hip hop music)
- That's fucking awesome.
- [Man] Good, right?
- I think you've got something.
- [Man] Cool.
- Somebody has to step up in this company
or we have to hire somebody
to do that shit 24/7.
I'm so fired up.
I'm now starting...
What we're doing doesn't work.
What we're going to do is,
whether Justin decides he wants
to do this or Seth or we
hire somebody, the context is
very simple, your fucking
life for next year
is to be great at that.
Prove it to...
Like we actually just did it.
Fuck it, chop this up I want to tweet it.
You guys see this shit, like fucking...
I want you to edit it
because you understand what I'm saying.
If you can make these things,
show the six or seven that work.
If you have the fucking
discipline to fucking eat shit
for two years on my
team for dick shit money
and look through all of
my fucking content over
the last two years,
especially the last year,
because there's nothing
but fucking jewels and
fucking facts everywhere
that you've never seen
because we can't fucking find them.
We fucking let them go.
Like, fuck, like, now we've
got something from no jumper.
No, when we come back,
people working on daily
be in the set, but you
fucking think it's great
to watch 18 fucking hours of
footage, 7 hours of footage.
You live for, you live
for watching that content
and finding the seven
little fucking minutes
and making this micro
fucking content for Snapchat
and Twitter and Facebook and Instagram.
These one minute fucking
memes that fucking
are straight fire, that are so magic.
If you want to eat shit
and you think that you're
great at it, submit right here.
I have no idea what
we're going to call it.
You're going to make a Google form.
It's going to be linked in all the things.
There's the url.
Garyvee.com/ICanDoIt
That's what it is.
Garyvee.com/ICanDoIt.
Go make the Google form now.
Submit your version of it.
Fucking strip the videos off
the fucking Youtubes and shit,
go to VideoLer if you're
a gangster, do your thing,
make the fucking video, and submit it.
Don't waste your time if you're dog shit
because D-rocks going to throw up on it.
If you've got this fucking
skill, go fucking make one
and I'll see you February
1st at VanyerMedia.
And I'm going to hire two
or three of you fuckers,
if you can actually do it.
No question for me.
The thought of entering
the Chinese market,
in a meaningful way around
my thoughts, my dreams,
my aspirations, the content,
obviously, you're aware of it,
but I agree 99.999999% of
people don't, in China.
And obviously for me, you know,
China is such a big part of
my future over the next 50
years and so as you know,
about a year and a half ago,
I started converting some
of my content into Mandarin
and things of that nature.
I produced profiles on some
of the bigger platforms Weibo,
and things of that nature.
Obviously, I've spent no
time in Asia prior to 2017.
I've been in Singapore and Hong Kong.
Next year, I'll be in
mainland China, twice.
I think 2019, 2020, I think
I'm going to come very hard
and so this is part of that.
And so I'm very excited
and I can't wait to meet
so many of you, whether
in New York or London
or China or Beijing, so I can't wait.
- Who are some of the
greatest communicators
that you ever met?
I know, perhaps, singling
someone is hard for you
but I'd love to know who
you think about is best.
- That's a great question.
Larry King.
Larry King interviewed me.
He's 80 something years old.
I was blown away by how
good he was, blown away.
Larry King is very high up for me.
Who I've met, Nipsey Hussle, the rapper.
He's so thoughtful about the
way he produces his songs
and he paints such a clear
picture of his truth.
He stands out for me.
I think Tim Ferriss is an
incredibly strong communicator.
I think he's very self aware
about what he's good at,
and I think he does a very good job
of communicating in his way.
Joe Rogan.
I think Joe Rogan's
podcast is very successful
because he's such a good communicator.
The mix between the way
he interviews and talks,
I'm not as good at that
because I talk over my guests.
He has the right balance
of letting them breath
but also getting in his.
So, those are some people that stand out.
Listen, here's my advice for men, women,
and everything in between,
the truth is undefeated.
I've been saying it for a very long time.
There's no hiding.
The gig is up.
And that's my advice for
everybody, for everything, forever.
So that's my advice for a
dirty old man in America.
That's my advice for China
around Tiananmen Square.
That's my advice about everything.
The truth, in the long
term, is undefeated.
If you do the wrong thing, you will lose.
You know, I know I'm American
but it's the same way I think
about an African American or
a female or a Latino girl.
I just think its
meritocracy and capitalism
and playing the game.
Of course I think that
woman are going to be
a bigger impact.
It's because the old rules didn't let them
get the fair amount of impact.
They're 100% equal.
They have different dynamics.
You know, men don't
give birth to children,
so they don't have that variable,
so we are different but
we're the same, do you know?
- [Woman] Mm-hmm.
- So, yeah, I don't even
think of it that way.
I'm excited that the world
is getting transparent.
I think a lot of people are not and
I think a lot of people are
scared of a transparent world,
including America,
including China and Russia.
Like, China, Russia, and America
are not going to let
block chain get too big.
- [Woman] You it grass.
- Patience.
Everybody is so impatient,
especially in the Asian markets.
You have to prove something
to your parents so much,
that you go so fast and so
hard just to get that chip
off your shoulder, either to pay them back
and you want to do good
for them or because
you're actually mad at them
and you want to stick it
to them, and so you start making
fast, short-term decisions
in your 20s of what you're supposed to do
and it screws you up for long term.
Thank you so much.
You did a great job.
(inaudible)
Of course, you did a great job.
Heading out, voice is shot, good day.
- [Woman] Thank you, Carter.
Thanks, Gary.
(upbeat music)